scp-682 versus a fighter jet who would
win well that depends on your definition
of win in terms of short-term
immobilization required for getting 682
recontained a fighter jet would likely
be an asset to any mtf hoping to get 682
back under control given its high speed
and weapons capable of at least
effectively stalling the monster however
if we're talking to the death then we'll
have to consider that missiles and
conventional arms fire have no lasting
effect against 682 given enough time it
would either adapt to either fly or
fling projectiles capable of taking the
jet down or both imagine a flying
missile launching 682
wow that's absolutely terrifying
scp-682 versus an m1 abrams tank who
would win while the m1 abrams is an
enduring piece of military technology
with strong offensive and defensive
capabilities is there actually a contest
to be had here 682 has survived
everything from the shy guy to the gate
guardian the only thing that a tank
would offer is a slightly longer time
spent unboxing 682's meal that being the
unfortunate operatives running the tank
the moral of today's short don't bring a
tank to an immortal anomaly fight
scp-682 vs scp-106
reptile versus old man the most hateful
scp versus the most sadistic who would
win this is another one we have a
precedent for these two engaged in a
likely three-way battle with scp-953
the polymorphic humanoid during a
containment breach all three were pulled
into 106's pocket dimension and the
battle took place there both returned
from the pocket dimension heavily
injured and were either easily subdued
or returned organically to their
containment chambers it was a draw we
can't imagine either of them would be
eager for a rematch anytime soon
scp-682 vs scp-053
what happens when you pit the
hard-to-destroy reptile against a very
lonely very deadly little girl this
foundation cross test allowed us to find
out 053 has the power to turn people
into violent maniacs who then
immediately die when they try to attack
her researchers hoped the same thing
would happen to scp-682
in fact the absolute opposite happened
053 seem to be one of the only creatures
in the universe that 682 becomes totally
docile around and despite 053's initial
fear of the beast she soon plucked up
the courage to approach and make a
friend the two played together with 682
even allowing 053 to draw on its face
both became distressed when the two
separated 053 began to cry and 682 went
berserk and started killing people sadly
for both of them the foundation has
deemed shared containment to be too much
of a risk to ever be allowed scp-682
vs
scp-662 can the world's greatest butler
transfer his skills into being the
world's best monster slayer and finally
bring an end to scp-682 when asked to
kill the beast he apologized profusely
and stated that he couldn't do it he
could perhaps distract 682 by
sacrificing himself to it at least as
the foundation persisted with their
questioning mr deeds made an alternate
suggestion perhaps if his body was laced
with a powerful toxin or booby trapped
with explosives then fed to scp-682
he could do more damage mr deeds was
dismissed shortly thereafter
scp-682 vs scp-061
could a mind-controlling music program
finally be the key to destroying the
infamous hard to destroy reptile 682
entered the relaxed state typical of
people undergoing 0-6-1 hypnosis at
first as the foundation gave a number of
menial orders such as rolling over 682
clearly tried to resist even entering a
violent seizure when ordered to stand up
it suddenly became immune to 061's
powers carrying out a violent assault on
the staff and breaching containment it
appeared to somehow integrate the
abilities of 061 into its own biology
releasing a screech that stunned
everybody nearby
and allowing it to devour several people
before it was re-contained
scp-682 vs
scp-524 the hard to destroy reptile
versus the cuddly widow bunny named roki
that can eat pretty much everything does
682 look enough like a big angry carrot
for walter to get the job done 682
regarded walter with suspicion as the
bunny approached it it then began
gnawing through 682's leg causing the
giant monster to bellow and flee he
chased 682 around the containment
chamber for several minutes before 682
tapped out 682 climbed up the wall of
the test chamber and waited while walter
washed his face with his paws 524 then
began chewing his way through the wall
of the test chamber at which point the
experiment was aborted still very good
try little buddy
scp-682 vs scp-513
sometimes to take down a scary scp like
scp-682 you need to bring in an even
scarier scp like this demonic cowbell
and the phantom it reveals
scp-682 was partially incinerated and
brought into a testing chamber where a
robotic arm rang the scp-513 bell
several times with the resulting sound
causing extreme stress for scp-682
aerosolized tranquilizers and sedatives
were pumped into the chamber causing 682
to fall unconscious it then began
sleepwalking breaching the containment
chamber but it wasn't alone a
nightmarish ghost-like entity resembling
682 began stalking the halls after mass
hysteria and mass staff death across the
site the foundation finally got things
back under control when scp-682 was
woken up it complained saying it was
having such a lovely dream
scp-2305-a an anomalous document that
manifests methods of neutralizing
various scps all of which are doomed to
fail so what did it have to say about
scp-682
to make a very long and elaborate story
short through a mix of anomalies and
massive hydrogen bombs
scp-682 would be transported to the moon
and blown to smithereens in a massive
ridiculous explosion earth is pounded by
the resulting meteors from the explosion
while only a tiny quantity of 682's
blood survived the bombardment it
managed to regenerate and adapt it
became the size of saturn and ended up
eating our solar system the moral of the
story don't redacted with this gecko
scp-682 vs scp-2521
an unspeakably cruel and violent reptile
versus a monster that is literally
unspeakable who won let's find out the
foundation used a laser cutting tool to
etch information about scp-2521
into the skin of
scp-682's side in the hopes that the
monster would turn up and steal
scp-682 however it didn't work out that
way instead it just appeared and tore
the skin off of 682's side before
demanifesting 682 regenerated the
missing skin later better luck next time
oh come on every time
scp-682 vs scp-811
could the sweet misunderstood swamp
woman finally end the wretched life of
the hard to destroy reptile let's find
out in a rare act of cross-test kindness
the foundation refused to pit 811
against 682 directly due to the
justifiable fear that it would simply
murder the swamp woman however the swamp
woman's deadly corrosive mucus was
harvested and applied to 682's skin the
fizzling muck was able to reduce 682's
body mass by 27
until the creature evolved a complete
bone covering of the remaining body mass
rendering the mucus ineffective but hey
at least this didn't cause any undue
stress to scp-811
scp-682 vs scp-2578-d
the hard-to-destroy reptile would kill
millions if ever it was allowed to
escape and be free would the
scp-2578-d impaler spacecraft be able to
put its reign of terror to an end
scp-2578-d is a mysterious spacecraft
with an immensely powerful and precise
proton cannon it seeks to protect
democracy and human rights from tyrants
fascists and authoritarians through
controlled assassinations or impaler
events one such event befell 682 in
containment with five cranial
penetrative wounds that pierced its
skull during a brief period leaving it
out of commission for 32 minutes it then
woke back up and yelled
all three of your moons
up to the ceiling the spacecraft later
sent an email to the foundation
apologizing that it hadn't killed 682 in
its defense though it hadn't missed a
single shot
scp-682 versus scp-2337
could the heart of destroy reptile meet
its end at the dangerously booming voice
of the talkative dr spankow as part of a
tissue test dr spanko was told 682's
flesh was a tone-deaf food critic who
needed to be convinced on what the
greatest food in existence was spanko
argued so loudly that the answer was
gummy worms that it destroyed 682's
flesh the next step was sending him in
to talk the actual 682 to death after
being told the reptile was an anti-gummy
worm extremist this seemed promising
until dr spanko confidently entered the
chamber and 682 simply boomed
at which point dr spanko turned
literally yelled the wall down and did
just that 682 must really hate gummy
worms
scp-682 versus scp-2617
could the icy operatives of the winter
command finally be the ones to take down
the hard to destroy reptile scp-682 was
airlifted into the abandoned russian
village where the 2617 radio tower was
situated and the foundation fed the
tower the reptile's coordinates as it
began attacking the village 2617
generated a large number of deadly ice
warriors who took on
scp-682 with both ferocity and skill
destroying 45 percent of its body mass
through sustained attacks it looked like
they might have the lizard on the ropes
until it began putting out its own radio
waves affecting and disrupting the 2617
radio tower as well as the researchers
in attendance the affected personnel
when later interviewed were unable to
recognize even the concept of russia
scp-682 vs scp-3930
could the patch of nothingness the true
oblivion in the heart of rural russia
finally consigned the nightmarish
reptile to non-existence let's see the
tissue sample from 682 was successfully
destroyed by being placed inside 3930
but the rest of the reptile would be a
little more complicated its body was
placed into the void and ceased existing
however despite ceasing to exist it
could still be perceived and slaughtered
several of the guards and researchers in
attendance thankfully it did eventually
disappear until 15 hours later when it
suddenly manifested once again in its
containment chamber good as new of
course nobody really knows how or why we
just don't question it at this point
scp-682 vs
scp-1056 could this anomalous body
warping kitchen timer finally be the
thing that shrinks scp-682 down to size
let's find out the objective of the test
was to see how long it would take
scp-682 to return to its normal size
after being resized by scp-1056
however when the creature was meant to
be shrunk to a quarter of its size it
simply disappeared it was later found
causing chaos outside of site-19 having
returned to its normal size when a
mobile task force was sent to apprehend
682 it released a wave that instead
massively shrunk the task force it
continued to rampage elsewhere
manipulating its size at will until a
combined group of mobile task forces
were able to incapacitate it researchers
concluded that it had not only absorbed
the anomalous effects of scp-1056
but enhanced it leading to considerably
more powerful defensive and offensive
body resizing capabilities
scp-682 vs scp-3207
no weapon the foundation has ever
created has been able to kill
scp-682 so maybe a crazy anomalous
energy cannon created by leonardo da
vinci and marco saul will get the job
done the tissue test went well as the
energy cannon was able to completely
vaporize the scp-682 flesh with a single
blast with this promising result they
went on to the full test 3207 appeared
to completely annihilate scp-682 with a
few well-aimed blasts leading to a great
deal of relief among the attending
researchers for a few hours at least
several nasty little creatures
regenerated from the scattered tissue of
scp-682
when these creatures breached
containment they fused back into scp-682
because of course they did
scp-682 vs
scp-393 so many of the foundation's
plans to kill scp-682 have failed but
maybe that's just because they never
wrote it down in scp-393
this singularly unique day planner
scp-393 is a day planner that bonds to a
nearby subject and when they write their
plans into it they will soon develop a
complete memory of having achieved those
plans perhaps this could be used to
figure out how to kill 682 a d-class was
given the planner and asked to write
going to somehow defeat
scp-682 today the d-class was later
found comatose with a horrified
expression on their face and died
shortly after a defeated note from a
young research assistant on the test
file reads it was worth a shot scp 682
versus an industrial grade blender
followed by strong centrifuge could this
the most hardcore of industrial kitchen
equipment finally take down the hard to
destroy reptile a 682 tissue sample was
reduced into a fine slurry by the
blender and then placed into the
centrifuge which slowly increased to a
truly insane number of rotations per
minute and the sample exploded severely
injuring 12 members of personnel and
almost killing dr carlson one of the
lead researchers on the project it
turned out that scp-682's flesh contains
antimatter hence the violent chemical
reaction that transpired naturally
further testing of this matter was
forbidden by the o5 council to reduce
the number of unnecessary explosions
occurring on the site i guess we'll
never truly know the outcome on this one
huh
scp-682 the indestructible reptile
versus
scp-241 good home cooking what happens
when you introduce the humanity-hating
lizard to a cookbook that sends the
person eating the recipes into
anaphylactic shock let's find out a
portion of 682 skin tissue was fixed to
a steel rod which was held by a d-class
and used to turn the pages of 241 the
cookbook displayed 99 new recipes
including three in an unknown language
two that were completely
incomprehensible and one that contained
a memetic kill agent the remaining
recipes all contained instructions that
made accurate preparation impossible
such as marinate for 900 trillion years
d-class personnel was tasked with
preparing these 93 recipes upon
completion each dish was served directly
to the lizard naturally it was able to
consume all 93 meals without any
difficulty for 682 this was most likely
one of the more enjoyable termination
attempts bon appetit
scp-682 the indestructible reptile
versus
scp-3519 a dangerous memetic contagion
responsible for killing nearly the
entire population of the world in a
certain timeline scp-3519 infected
global media to influence the public
into believing that the world would end
on march 5th 2019. group of foundation
personnel decided to test 3519's
exposure with 682 in hopes that it might
terminate the lizard once and for all
lowering the acid levels inside its tank
682 was exposed to the contagion but did
not show any self-destructive ideation
instead 682 nightmarishly laughed for
193 seconds before it was placed back
into containment after march 5th there
was only one lone human survivor junior
researcher dr rory jones when 682
encountered the doctor after breaching
containment it did not kill him instead
it simply stated we are like now meat
killing you would only end suffering
scp-682 the indestructible reptile
versus scp-1237 the epsilon wave who
would win
scp-1237 is a brain pattern occurring in
deep rem sleep that allows an
individual's dreams to shape and affect
reality when they wake one specimen
affected by scp-1237 was permitted to
observe scp-682 and was instructed to
dream that scp-682 was a small house cat
with no anomalous abilities and that the
foundation had successfully terminated
it seven seconds into their sleep the
subjects seized violently and died less
than a minute later alongside 13 other
observing security personnel their
bodies were covered with scratches and
bites as well as symptoms of
toxoplasmosis and bubonic plague inside
scp-682's chamber was a small house cat
licking blood from its coat of fur it
regenerated into scp-682 only a few
hours later looks like in this matchup
the lizard not the cat got the
foundation's tongue as expected
scp-682 versus a vacuum and we're not
talking about the household cleaning
appliance could the hard-to-destroy
reptile survive in a completely air-free
environment to find out 99 of the oxygen
was removed from a testing chamber that
scp-682 was trapped inside the creature
entered a dormant state and began
producing what the foundation believed
to be its native atmosphere a mixture of
56 ozone 23 chlorine 18 xenon and other
caustic elements the test was eventually
called to an end however when our normal
earth atmosphere was reintroduced into
the room it reacted with the compound
that 682 was releasing and caused a
massive explosion that blew off the
blast door a scientist remarked that it
was no wonder 682 was so hardy if that
poisonous mix was its native atmosphere
scp-682 vs
y-909 can the compound derived from
scp-3000 the legendary anatashia be the
thing that finally ends the wretched
life of scp-682
y-909 is the key ingredient in
foundation amnestics and the researchers
discovered a curious thing when it was
added to 682's tank it caused an
increase in the damage that hydrochloric
acid did to the creature's body this
suggested that 682's regenerative
abilities are somehow tied to its
memories of previous damage taken some
researchers proposed taking scp-682
directly to scp-3000 to see if the giant
eel could kill 682 once and for all
however this proposal was soundly
rejected due to too many unpredictable
factors from the risk of transporting
682 to its unpredictable adaptive
response to scp-3000 such as growing to
scp-3000's insane size or stealing
insemnistic abilities